the following broadcast is rated s for
spoilers
do you like tv shows how about a tv show
about some tv shows about some tv shows
that
is a tv show watched by the characters
inside a tv show
wandavision the tv show
you said huh when they bonded over their
vaguely defined superpowers
i'm still me i think do you know i don't
know what this is
you said oh okay when they date it for
two years off camera
wonder for two years we stole these
moments
and you thought well i guess that's over
when this happened
but ever since cap left bucky for this
homewrecker
wanda and vision are the closest thing
marvel has to a healthy relationship
even though she's torturing a small town
with her mind when you let us sleep
we have your nightmares your grief is
poisoning us
and he's her imaginary vibrator
programmed only to love
you can't control me the way you do them
can't i
watch this power couple cosplay through
some of history's most delightful
sitcoms
from modern family it's probably just a
case of the mondays
to malcolm in the middle mom's been
weird since uncle pietro got here
to the show's boomers love because they
literally had no other options
take out the papers and the trash or you
won't get no spending cash
but every once in a while this super
computer manages to calculate
something about all this might not be on
the up and up i have questions
what is it how did this happen she came
here because we're all what
what was that about what aren't you
telling me why are there no other
children in worcester no am i dead
why would you think that i guess you are
because the big question of the series
isn't so much what's gonna happen
but more what the [ __ ] is even happening
i don't know
i don't know and i don't know in a story
that's really about one is grief and
finding acceptance
the acceptance that no matter how
original a marvel thing starts off
it still has to end with a sky beam and
two cgi dolls throwing particle effects
at each other
it's just so meaningful this reminds me
of my own struggles i'm sorry i just
need a second
but there's more to the show than an
expanding red bubble of sadness that
makes america great again
step outside the hecks to meet
characters like darcy
the latest phase of marvel's image rehab
campaign for thor the dark world
jimmy wu the only cop who's also into
close-up magic that anyone could ever
love
and monica rambo who grows from a
knowing commentary on tv's black best
friend trope
into an actual example of tv's black
best friend trobe they'll never know
what you sacrificed for them
and finally into a superhero who could
one day become
marvel's first black best friend trope
in
space together they'll take on some
brand new villains
like this generic military jerk ass
dottie who
actually thought he doesn't really
matter and the head which in charge
agatha hargness
a well-brewed concoction of one part
maleficent and two parts cruella de vil
and i killed sparky too
let your love for katherine han blind
you to the fact that her plan doesn't
make a ton of sense
and her past implies that the salem
witch trials were kinda onto something
and despite what her absolute pop of the
theme song claims
she barely knows what's going on either
i need you to tell me how you did this
i couldn't make heads or tails of it
it's been wanda's repressed trauma
all along but agatha kind of not turned
that direction doesn't exactly
top the charts though huh are you a
hardcore marvel fan
then you know wandavision wasn't meant
to be enjoyed but dissected frame by
frame
to predict what's coming next as the
show spawned a q anon style army of
forecasters who were so
sure that mephisto was behind it all the
devil's in the details bev
that's not the only place he is nope
just a deep cut easter egg
evan peters casting was proof of the
multiverse
wrong just an elaborate boner joke boner
and that the last episode had to have a
luke skywalker level cameo
i work with this actor that i have
always wanted to work with oh
and you have fireworks together
how about paul bettany giving himself
head instead
why can't you just accept the fact that
the big bad for the mcu's first disney
plus series was grief
this [ __ ] you have to spell it out on an
announcement board or something
so if you've been feeling sad and
hopeless lately and just want to
mentally check out and fill all the
voids in your life with garbage tv
catch the story of a superhero who does
pretty much
exactly that and at the end of the day
after all the trauma
follow her to the place all marvel
characters go once their arcs are done
some lonely ass cabin in the woods
i'm so blue
storing i'm a witch i'm a mother an
avenger had a brother wanda's nose
grunge
i'll see what curtain called that was
radical
get the skin thing cuddles and kisses
between his little ears
weekend at bed knees what white nonsense
is this
agatha crispy a spectrum representative
will arrive anytime between the hours of
1 and 9
boner save the cat who's clues
wrecking ralph the only way ralph would
remember our anniversary is if there was
a beard named june
2nd what ralph could really use is how
to goose your wife so you don't lose
your wife
ralph looks better in the dark so i'm
not complaining not that ralph ever
wants to eat anything other than baked
beans
which explains a lot about his personal
appeal mind you you sure you don't want
an
audience volunteer named my husband
ralph oh
hey where'd you blow me wanda's twin
powers activate
going through hex
and what is this show if not joy
disappearing do you have a brother mom
he's far away from here and that
makes me sad sometimes he was killed by
ultron maria died three years ago
before what i can't remember my life
before westfield i don't know who i
am you probably suppressed a lot of the
trauma you're so
crippled by your own self-doubt all you
people who left
still have the luxury of optimism you
have no idea what it was like
oh it's lost i only remember feeling
completely alone endless nothingness
so much trauma zakana will be
sorrow can it parents dead
brother dead vision dead
i have a daughter if you could just let
her out of her room if
i could just hold her i can't feel you
thanks for choosing me
to be your mom you are my sadness
pecs in the city
if one ever needs backup she should just
call her neighbor murtaugh from lethal
weapon
i'm too old for this hey screen junkies
are you the ultimate mcu fan click the
link to sign up for the fandom five
trivia contest and win real money for
all your made-up knowledge
more of a dc person click the link to
join our live four-hour watch-along of
the snyder cut
no bathroom breaks allowed like a good
neighbor
stay home if you're not feeling well
you're a witch wander
we must avenge sparky your name is ralph
boner
every word in the dictionary i'm doing
this
but only because i choose to